Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my video for the boys season 2
teaser that they just released for
stormfronts character they explained a
whole bunch of what's going on with the
storyline when things are when they pick
up in Episode one there's a bunch of
Easter eggs so we'll break it all down
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos for the
boys season two we're actually going to be
getting episodes way sooner than I
thought so we'll just break this down
top five style and it is very as
you would expect from the boys starting
with number five meet I Akash as
Stormfront from the boys comics one of
the worst characters next to Homelander
if not even worse because of her origin
story if you've read the boys comic book
they have made some changes to stormfronts backstory in the way they're
using the character in the war between
the boys in the seven during season two
does the same way that they changed the
comic book plot during season one so no
big surprise that they changed things a
little bit Anthony's star the actor who
plays Homelander says that she's
basically the grenade that gets thrown
into Homelander world in the world of
the seven Homelander says she causes me
so many problems so many different types
of problems what are those problems I'll
get into those in a second because some
of them are a little bit funnier and
than the others some of them are
physical problems like actual fighting
but some of them are much more
complicated so number four Homelander
versus stormfront in the war
between the boys in the seven what is
her relationship with Homelander in the
seven what is her relationship with
Billy butcher in the boys because in the
comics stormfront actually spends most
of his comic book story with Billy
butcher in the boys that's where you get
most of that you also find out a lot
about the team that stormfront leads in
the comics like the seven is the main
team like the Justice League or the
Avengers of the world of the boys
they're the a-list heroes but there are
other really big superhero teams stormfront leads a team called payback even
though there are a ton of characters and
a ton of agendas going on inside the
world of the boys everyone has their own
angle that they're trying to play it's
mostly a story about Billy butcher
trying to use the boys to tear down the
seven in people's perception of the
seven these are superheroes they're
terrible people and even though Billy
butcher doesn't have super powers in the
traditional sense his real superpower is
actually the way he uses information
against superheroes so he learns all
about their weaknesses usually he gets
that information through all kinds of
different means through intimidation
through blackmail any way that he can so
in the comics Billy butcher tries to use
stormfront against homeland err I don't
know if they're necessarily implying
it's going to be exactly like that during
season two for the most part stormfront
is meant to be a character that homeland
er can't intimidate the way that he
intimidates everyone else everyone is
terrified of him we've seen that during
season one because he is the world's
most powerful superhero the thing about
stormfront is that she's almost as
powerful as him more powerful than Queen
Maeve like they say that within the
world of the seven Queen Maeve is also
one of the world's strongest superheroes
but she can't fly she doesn't have
nearly as many abilities as home planner
is and she's not quite as invulnerable
just to make a Dragon ball Z analogy
stormfront is kind of like the Vegeta
of the series just in terms of power
scaling so if Homelanderis an evil
version of Goku imagine Stormfront is a
more evil version of Vegeta so even
though they might not be at each other's
throats
all the time there is this rivalry
between the two of them if you haven't
read the comics obviously all the
superheroes are meant to be parodies of
traditional DC Comics and Marvel Comics
superheroes Stormfront is meant to be a
parody of Thor in Shazam she can fly she
has Lightning based powers like she can
literally spit lightning out of her
mouth the way the actors are describing
stormfronts storyline when things pick
up during season 2 episode 1 is that
she's thrown into the mix into the 7 and
she becomes this Chernobyl for them
causing them to melt down starting with
homeland ur number 3 stormfronts
costume and all the big comic book
changes they made in a bunch of Easter
eggs that you're probably spotting here
this is what stormfronts costume looks
like in the comics so obviously this is
the modern version of that because in
the comics stormfront is actually one
of the original if not the original
superhero created by Vaught during World
War two they didn't really get into it
during season one of the TV series but
you have this line of superheroes
originating from all these German
experiments during World War Two from
the Third Reich and that's basically
where Vaught developed the technology
for creating superheroes and compound B
so after World War 2 Opera
and paperclip happened and you have all
these German scientists including Vogel
BOM who created compound B coming to the
United States taking on new identities
and that's when they created bought
American and started their modern
incarnation when they created Homelander based on all the technology that
they use developing Stormfront so even
though there's no biological
relationship between these two
characters stormfront was kind of like
the beta version of Homelander so
notice all the paraphernalia
mixed with the American flag armbands is
a little bit similar to what's going on
with home lenders character but in a
much more overt way and obviously
referencing the comic book version of
the character so it's not like she's
going to be going full-blown or
anything like that the way this reads to
me is this should be something of a
supremacist the actors also call
stormfronts character very
old-fashioned in her beliefs but very
modern in her practices I'll explain
what that modern means in a second
Anthony star who plays Homelander says
that stormfront on the TV show isn't
quite into the celebrity culture and
fanfare that the seven are in the way he
describes Homelander versus stormfront
is this also the social media public
perception aspect to it because it's all
about the way the public perceives the
seven and apparently homeland is just
terrible at social media he has all
these other people running their
accounts remember what happened to
butcher's wife during season one I know
everyone's still wondering did she
willingly sleep with him what was going
on with all that are they going to
explain it during season two remember
that she was initially hired by bot to
handle all the social media in marketing
for Homelander so because there's
something of a competition going on
between Homelander and stormfront it
sounds like stormfront is also going to
be using a lot of social media in public
perception to twist up Homelander in a
way that he can't fight with his fists
they get into it in the comics a little
bit more but the whole point of Vaud
american creating super heroes in the
first place is purely to earn money in
order to do that they create all this
merchandise they create comic books
based on fake backstories they create
movies like all the fake movies that
black noir is starring in with Seth
Rogen's director character all of that
is part of a giant propaganda
merchandising machine for the purposes
of earning more money so while homelander is the world's most powerful
superhero physically
he could kill everyone on the planet if
he wanted to he doesn't want to do that
he wants a family he wants everyone's
love and admiration which is why that's
a huge weakness for him so obviously
stormfront is going to be using those
weaknesses against him during season two
number two stormfronts powers so
she's almost as invulnerable as Homelander
she can fly just like Homelander
but she can also give off lightning so
if you saw this Shazam movie if you saw
any Marvel movie with Thor in it it's
basically like that the way the actors
the producers talk about stormfront
versus homeander during season two is
that she knows how to play him and will
do everything she can to avoid a
one-on-one fight with him knowing that
she would probably lose so a lot of the
things that she'll be doing will be more
sinister in addition to the traditional
comic book fair obviously she has cool
powers she's super strong so you're
going to see her beat the crap out of a
bunch of people think about it this way
though they're both Psychopaths she's
just a slightly different type of
psychopath than Homelander but number
one one of the episodes coming out
when's the next big trailer going to
drop in what's going on with the boys
season 3 so the good news is it sounds
like they've already soft renewed the
boys for season 3 Karl Urban said that
he wasn't taking on a lot of other giant
film projects because he was so
committed quote-unquote to the boys
meaning that he would be busy filming
the boys season 3 later this year
they'll be screening the first 10
minutes or so of the boys season 2
episode 1 this Sunday but I think that's
going to be a private event I don't know
if they're going to drop all 10 minutes of
that online whatever they wind up
releasing I will totally do a video for
but it's supposed to be the first 10
minutes of season 2 episode 1 they said
that because season 1 was so popular
they gave them a giant budget for season
2 so there's going to  be way more
characters way more craziness way more
big battles Karl Urban also revealed
that the season 2 episode 1 release date
was going to be somewhere around the
middle of the summer but they could move
that up because of all the Disney Plus
Falcon and Winter Soldier stuff is going to
be dropping later this summer so they
might want to try and avoid that so good
news is we might get season 2 episode 1
even earlier than July but everyone let
me know in the comments if you have any
big questions about the boys season 2
what's going on of course I'll do more
bonus videos when they drop new footage
or a new big details it's going to be crazy
in the best possible way whisper old
season 3 episode 1 is also starting on
Sunday night I'll be 2
weekly videos for that so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all those videos when I post
them every one click here for that brand
new black widow trailer with all the new
taskmaster Avengers scenes and click
here for that new boys season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight